hi how are you i'm good how about you
good thank you
i very much enjoyed watching this last
season and i'm curious what has playing
emily dickinson giving you what have you
learned from bringing her to life for
three seasons
i don't even know where to begin uh
playing this character has really
it's taught me so much about
what it means to take ownership of
of yourself and and
how to how to really be yourself and
live
your life unapologetically um
emily dickinson is someone who
lived through a time where she was very
misunderstood and and and really unseen
and unheard she spent the majority of
her life feeling that way
and it never stopped her from doing what
made her feel most alive and she didn't
do it for
the acclaim she didn't do it for
validation she did it because it was
what made her feel like her and and
alive um and i love that i feel like i
you know can look back at someone like
her who made it through
the time that she lived through um
and by by doing what she does best and
and i feel like if i can if i if i look
at her and think she was able to do it
then then i must be able to do it now so
i find her incredibly inspiring and i
feel very lucky that i was able to play
her
you obviously have experience with
scripts and dialogue but what what's it
like to get to deliver this poetry and
to really sort of
live in that poetry when you get to
deliver those words
i the the language in this show overall
um was something that definitely stood
out to me uh the fact that there is a
very modern twist to it a modern feel
but when it came to her poetry
i was always so
blown away by how it never felt like
once we started to hear the poetry
you didn't feel taken out of
it by any means it just suddenly became
natural and it felt so real uh and so
relevant and the way that this this
poetry is sort of integrated into the
show i think is so smart um and the way
you
hear it and the way you see it on the
screen um and while you're hearing it
and while you're reading it you're
watching what we think might have been
going on in emily's life or in her mind
when she was writing that poem uh and it
just brings each and every line of those
poems to life and uh
yeah i mean they're incredible so to be
able to to voice them has
been very exciting
what's it like to have had the
collaboration the partnership with elena
smith for three seasons how does the
actor show runner relationship compared
to
the actor director relationship you've
had on films
elena and i had a conversation uh it was
actually really the first time that we
sat down in person uh before we started
shooting and we were in new york city
and
i was a little
um
let's just say i had never experienced
any kind of director switching uh
while playing one character um and i was
i didn't know how to feel about it i was
obviously very excited about everybody
that we were about to bring onto the
show but i was a little nervous in
developing this character having so many
people to do that with before i had the
chance to feel like i had it myself um
was a little daunting and elena had
looked at me and said listen
you and i
are here i am not going anywhere these
directors might be switching out every
two two and a half weeks whatever it was
but i
will be here and from that point on our
collaboration has really been
um
non-stop in a way and and it's been
really amazing to sort of get into her
head and and be a part of this vision
that she has had in there for so long um
and she just is she's i call her my
emily dickinson encyclopedia she just
like anytime i have any questions she's
got the answer um but she's been really
awesome uh through this whole process
and i'm i'm again just so honored that i
was able to be a part of her vision
after finishing up with dickinson you
got to jump into doing hawkeye
what was it actually like to make a
marvel series compared to what you
thought it might be or what you expected
going into it
uh well first of all it was definitely
um
wild going from uh
an 1860s period drama comedy wearing
corsets and
all that
going straight into
the marvel universe wearing a
superhero suit and
i was in the middle of these car chases
and these crazy action-packed um
stunt driven scenes uh that was took me
a second to uh wrap my head around that
but
so amazing i feel so again lucky to be a
part of something so
special and kate bishop is a character
that i
continue to discover more and more about
that i just love i mean i think i can't
love her anymore and then i
discover something new and it's
mainly exciting to see that this is a
character the fans have wanted to see
come to life for a very long time and um
yeah it's it's a good one i'm ready for
everyone to see it
how much has kevin feige and marvel told
you about the arc of the character going
forward do you feel like you have a
sense of what could come next for her or
do you feel as in the dark as the fans
uh i
well the thing about i think they're
they're you might be able to get a sense
by the end of uh of hawkeye um what her
deal is and it's been really exciting to
sort of develop her and and
um introduce her story and her
background to the world uh through this
show uh and i'm just very excited for
people to see it and i can't wait to
hear what they think
i love the relationship between emily
and lavinia it's
especially in this season they're
they're really both just having to be
there for each other
what was the experience of forming that
sister bond as characters and and as
actors because it's just there's
something so lovely about watching the
two of you thank you so much anna and i
have had such a fun time together i i
through seasons one and two
and of course three uh i anytime i got
to have a scene with anna i was always
especially
excited i think she
is so incredible in this show and she
balances this very fine line of
this this this dramatic and comedic
performance um that i mean every time i
i will read through an episode i
am just like instantly excited about
what lavinia gets to do right and then
when i get to actually see anna do it
and play through these moments that are
actually very complicated and and
layered um
is is it's always she really blows me
away and and um
i
love that in this season we really get
to see
emily open up to lavinia in a way that
she hasn't before
and we get to see lavinia
accept not that she ever
didn't in the past but we get to see her
really appreciate the fact that her
sister is who she is and and for the
first time there's this connection where
we see them see each other we see
lavinia see emily and although in the
past you know she's kind of rolled her
eyes and thought my sister is so
eccentric and she just does her own
thing and she's so you know we are so
not on the same page i think she finally
realizes that she is who she is and she
loves her for who she is and it's a
really beautiful moment
emily and sue were in a bit of a love
bubble in season two because nobody
really knew about them but in season
three
it seems that sue is making some more
demands on emily what did you enjoy
about
that dynamic this season and really sort
of getting to see where that whole
journey ends up
well i always i've always loved that
whenever emily and sue are together they
really are
their truest selves
and
in season three
they're definitely in um very specific
points in their own personal lives but
sue continues to be this person for
emily that pushes her to be true to
herself and and
um own her take ownership of herself and
so she kind of pushes her in this season
a little bit and like you said she makes
these demands that that she hasn't in
the past and emily respects her and
emily has this this
love for her that is so
deeply rooted um and regardless of where
she is in her life and and how she's
interconnected into the family she has
this love for her that can never be
diminished and um
it'll never go away and it's a really
really
lovely and
beautiful relationship and i am so um
pleased with how we've played through it
how do you feel about the final moment
and what the last parting
moment is that we get to see of emily
it's very bittersweet and i'll never
forget shooting it um
and sort of being
on my own uh and having this real moment
of
looking out into
the future and
not necessarily knowing what it holds
and and again
this show has continued to um
sort
of shock me or or maybe even scare me a
little bit with these parallels that
they've that they have in in our world
now um and in my life personally and the
last day of shooting anything is is like
i mean
you're like you mean i don't have to
show up here tomorrow morning and and be
on time for something and and give
myself to something else and be prepared
like what am i going to do with my life
i this is it
and i have this moment of like pure
hope and and and excitement towards the
future and with the civil war being the
time that emily wrote the majority of
her poems having that moment where we
get to see her look out into this world
of what is to come
uh is really beautiful and um
yeah it was a real moment for me as well
because i i feel i had a similar one
well thank you beautiful work in this i
appreciate it thanks so much
thank you
you